Nos dicen: "Dibuja la imagen del triángulo
ABC con una homotecia cuyo centro sea P y el
factor de escala sea ¼", y lo que vemos
aquí es una herramienta en Khan Academy
donde podemos hacer esto. Entonces tenemos esta
figura, este triángulo ABC justo aquí, y lo que
queremos hacer es aplicar una homotecia, lo que
significa escalarlo hacia arriba o hacia abajo,
y el centro de esa homotecia es este punto P. Una
forma de pensar en esto es considerar la distancia
entre el punto P y cada uno de estos puntos, y
como queremos escalarla a ¼, entonces la distancia
será ¼ de lo que era antes. Por ejemplo, veamos
este punto aquí, si sólo miramos la diagonal de
P a A, podemos ver que está cruzando un cuadrado,
dos cuadrados, tres cuadrados, cuatro cuadrados,
por lo que, si tenemos un factor de escala de ¼
en lugar de cruzar cuatro cuadrados en diagonal,
sólo cruzaríamos un cuadrado en diagonal, así
que pondré el punto correspondiente a A justo
ahí. Ahora, ¿qué pasa con el punto C? No es
tan obvio, pero una forma de pensar en esto es:
¿qué distancia hay horizontalmente entre P y
C? y, luego ¿qué distancia hay verticalmente?
Horizontalmente tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 de
estas unidades, y luego verticalmente tenemos 1,
2, 3, 4, entonces son 8 a la izquierda y 4
hacia arriba. Ahora, si tenemos un factor de
escala de ¼, simplemente multiplicamos cada uno
de ellos por ¼, por lo que en lugar de ir a la
izquierda 8 iríamos a la izquierda 2, 8 veces
¼ es 2, y en lugar de subir 4 subiríamos 1,
así que este sería el punto correspondiente a
C; y luego hacemos lo mismo para el punto B:
cuando vamos de P a B, tenemos 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 hacia arriba,
y tenemos 4 a la izquierda; si tenemos un factor
de escala de ¼ en lugar de subir 8 subiremos 2,
y en lugar de ir 4 a la izquierda iremos 1 a la
izquierda. Ahí lo tenemos, acabamos de aplicar
homotecia al triángulo ABC alrededor del punto P
con un factor de escala de ¼. Y hemos terminado.